hello and welcome to studio playing f
ms.m 3-m so an English opening d6 okay
yeah this is an interesting interesting
a line I do it go I don't know if I'd
let b5 sa-6 anyway so yeah interesting
right place a little bit like like him
Kalashnikov Sicilian okay can i goone
try go Bishop g2 takes takes Bishop c4
between a 4 hmm doesn't look super
convincing him a 95 s the 95 is such a
weak move I just react at all okay can i
play this as some sort of gambit so we
would provocative but he has no
development if he takes and he doesn't
want to it just never never reacts to
any offers of material and so on
probably justifiably so okay so i'll
i'll go for this and try to do something
here
looks a bit weakening but I definitely
oops not to move ahead on the radar
hmm yeah tough I have got a very good
center but maybe he has some counter
play against it not currently not seeing
it so much but might be yeah this was
one booth in the night night to h4 is
potentially there is a is a potential
continuation yeah
night too i don't i don't know how to
expel this night in this okay i'm going
here night h4 I thought you should f-22
g3 okay
he wants to take here maybe and
sacrifice at a conscious free antigua
form now yes here so he has pressure
against the center absolutely
again if you want to sack I really don't
see much that I can do about it okay
yeah this is this chick here coming and
hmm doesn't look good
ok
I'm not even sure that this works
actually can just take you four maybe I
mean even strategically this is just
fantastic for black
check
the ending isn't a big issue I think if
he takes it now this is something that I
would have been okay with I mean I'm not
I'm not happy i wouldn't would have
wouldn't have been happy in the ending
but it was a wasn't losing or anything
yeah things coming to g4 I have to
prevent so we try to put that night to
III maybe two III yeah no I'm giving him
the b5 square it wasn't necessary really
hmm sure thought about that a little bit
more
maybe you could have accepted yeah I
don't want to trade but I probably have
to this is a bad no this is bad news if
I have to have to throw it absolutely
time morning bad news jack mmm 9393 i am
playing terribly I'm just playing
terribly here this game ah it has a
double made Queen you won and tween f2
made well i played this like a child
really really badly why resides terrible
game absolutely terrible game yeah here
this is this a sign he also he allowed
this and this is a very very difficult
position to play I have the center and
the bishop pair but he has this this
these pieces they really pressurize the
center a lot and this is an issue and I
should have played you five here in this
position that wasn't that it was an
opportunity I mean it's clear that i
played a really bad game and missed
missed opportunities and this is this is
good it's very good I mean it's not very
good for white in terms of white being
usually better but I should still play
the move because now the content at
least is going forward I mean this is
this is probably just bad the computer
wants to go back and then i have e 6
there is a lot better than
here this is this is just very difficult
to play and blacks play is very easy and
he can just attack the center and yes
multiple ways of doing that yeah this
decision is of course debatable but what
am i doing him and I just hate the
position i mean i have a bad king and
the center is very vulnerable Jack Kim
and I think he did a good job here I
mean okay the trades i think they were
kind of okay for me but it's always
black being better him the dark squares
are weak my bishop is bad and so on I
actually felt that it didn't go so badly
but yeah after I left that trade I have
to trade here I'm just just lost here I
think this is ultimately losing of
course making making things worse but it
was just a bad position very interesting
opening play yeah maybe I should do
something more conventional just just
this bit surprised that the engine gives
white almost a winning position here and
that that's probably just not right I
don't think this is this is true however
it is really good actually I mean this
this 94 and I'm winning stuff so I
should have played simple chance as
usual as this is better than f4 yeah i
mean even if I just do this this is
ofcourse comfortable for white but I
wanted to do something more ambitious
with their form okay it was a good game
but not by me just by my opponent thanks
for watching